and we've developed this culture where
the victim has almost become sacred so
there's a sort of supply and demand
issue with trauma that everybody in a
way wants to be traumatized and you guys
have talked a lot about activists and
people who are kind of you know they're
hyper Vigilant a lot of the time they're
looking for something that's hurt them
they're looking in a paranoid kind of
way it's oh you must be a racist you
must be a sexist that's not the only
thing that's going on but one of the
things that's going on is that people
have been hurt have been abused and they
um
have come to see the world as a
threatening place and they're looking
for threat everywhere so you know victim
is the opposite of agency is the
opposite of healing and I think one of
the big problems in our society is that
we don't have a way to be good
and we need that and it's almost a very
old-fashioned idea it's sort of the
ethics and virtue and morality but we
need that as people we need a way to be
good and in the absence of that people
will adopt whatever they're offered
which may be a good consumer or a good
social justice person is like all you
have to do to be good is this is say
this thing on social media all right so
it offers people a cheap and easy way to
be good like we pretend that strength as
a vice and weakness as a virtue and it's
not
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is an
embodiment teacher and Trauma educator
who's worked in Conflict zones like
Sarah Afghanistan and more recently
Ukraine Mark Walsh welcome to
trigonometry pleasure to be here uh and
I didn't mention the intro you've had
your own experiences with cancellations
and you know people not liking what you
say and stuff so I'm sure we'll get into
all of that before we do though tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us sure well
first of all I'm very happy right now
because you're just giving me steaks so
um that's the first for me on interviews
it's what we do man
well fed well it's good actually
somebody wrote a hit piece about us or
mostly about me and one of the main
criticisms was when he came in here we
were having steak it's a you're now
problematic as well I am My Vegan
friends in Brighton are going to be
upset
um
so that's what they do best
um grew up in East Anglia I was just
saying to American friends I call it the
Alabama of England I was um from the
fence uh come from a family of teachers
and crazy people basically and um my
story in some ways is parallel to that
of Western civilization in that I was
really bright cognitively but was a
complete screw-up and by the time I was
17 I was very alcoholic drug addicted
suicidal
just a mess and my dad was an alcoholic
so I kind of grew up in that kind of
trauma soup and um thought you know what
I go to University study psychology
figure out what's going on here
um but by that point I kind of thought
you know what maybe the answer isn't in
a book
and I went to a martial arts school I
was involved in sort of low-level crime
and things I thought it'd be a good idea
to learn martial arts and I went in
there and I saw into a dojo for the
first week at University and it just
spoke to me and there was discipline and
beauty and it just something in me went
you need that
and I I just devoted myself to martial
arts barely went into the Library
University
and um you know I did this psychology
degree but um yeah for me I perceived
the martial arts I was a living martial
arts student and then that sort of
opened up into uh dance yoga meditation
improv uh theater the whole field that I
would Now call the embodiment field
which is all the things that work with
the body is a bit more than a brain taxi
and realized there was a whole sort of
another education out there which would
be very obvious to say a Japanese person
you know they would do martial arts in
school and develop a character through
that but wasn't obvious to me and um
eventually started teaching that I teach
a lot of coaches now
uh was working in non-profit sector for
quite a while so I was um working in
various areas of conflict
and yeah most recently in Ukraine it's a
bit of an emotional day today actually
because it's uh today's anniversary of
the invasion as you know so
um a lot of messages coming in before
this sort of quite um quite emotional so
um I've got that kind of churned up a
little bit today and we'll talk about
that of course are you and when I
introduce you as embodiment teacher I
imagine most people are going huh what
the hell is that what the hell is that
yeah yeah my family still do that
um so it's kind of like this are they
still telling you to get a real job no I
did it I did a job with the House of
Lords on trauma about 10 years back and
then my dad went oh my God this must be
a real job but until that point
um yeah they definitely even for
Christmas and stuff they're like what is
it you do again
um
so it's a way of looking at a human
being so I train a lot of coaches I work
with business people different ways to
describe it but it's a form of
intelligence essentially
um so you can be cognitively smart but
you could also be smart with people you
can be emotionally intelligent you know
you can charismatic you can be I don't
know good Under Pressure all those
things are part of embodied intelligence
and it's also just a kind of
umbrella term for all the kind of
mindfulness based body Arts so not so
much exercise not so much physicality
more the body as who we are the body is
relates to who we are as people I'm very
interested in that from a lens of trauma
and culture and Leadership and different
different
um things within that that sounds really
really interesting so
trauma we talk about it a lot but I
don't think that people actually
understand what is meant by the term
trauma what is trauma and how can it
impact people's lives yeah I mean it's
become a kind of fashionable term right
like everybody's traumatized Yeah by
everybody else in a way which I find a
bit silly particularly when I look at
some of my messages today
um so overwhelming events so
overwhelming events
um create us get stuck in that fight or
flight or freeze response so most people
understand the idea of fight or fly
we'll have that bit of stress in our
lives going on
um but if that's chronic you're
chronically there that impacts your
deception cognition critically or
relationships
or in the freeze response where people
are more shut down you'll see this more
in Eastern Europe
um close down them you know they're not
smiling they're not being so empathic
perhaps and that makes relationships
very difficult it means that people are
very unhealthy physically quite often it
can show up in loads and loads of ways
across different domains but yeah being
stuck in that fight or flight of freeze
response is one very simple definition
usually coming from experiences of um
overwhelm and powerlessness and
um yeah it's a fascinating topic it's a
trendy topic it's been hijacked by the
left we can talk about that and um you
know for me it's just a very practical
thing as well with some of the work I do
it's interesting that you mentioned
sorry for instance there's a political
Dimension to it I found that a bit odd
actually it is it's very strange so um
where to begin with this
um
I'm just trying to find the way in
that's best to sort of think about this
so most psychologists are on the left
okay there's kind of you know Jordan
Peterson maybe and a couple of others
who are more conservative or more
Centrist even so they have a particular
way of looking at the world that way of
looking at the world
um could be uh that it's Society or
culture that causes problems yeah and
it's not the individual's fault or
responsibility and there's definite
truth to that so for example there's a
psychologist called gabo mate who's very
well known I think does great work and
he says hey it's not your fault it's
Society it's culture and that is an
important perspective uh but I would say
it's probably not the only one
the other thing is our cultures become
somewhat psychologized in the it's
become a weapon
so if I say you've upset me that's one
level but if I say you've traumatized me
or you know you're an abuser or
something like that that's a much higher
accusation and we've developed this
culture where
the victim has almost become sacred
so there's a sort of supply and demand
issue with trauma that everybody in a
way wants to be traumatized because then
it's like okay then I get certain
accommodation
um and I think it is a way of looking at
the world if some somebody has trauma
they feel unsafe
right the world has become a dangerous
place so what do you do about that and
one response is to try and control the
world
try and control people's
speech thinking Etc
um I think a sort of integrated approach
that takes both a left and the right
wing perspective is
a healthier perspective
for looking at trauma more sort of
holistically the other thing is
sometimes it just seems a little bit
like first world problems these days
particularly compared to Ukraine or
somewhere like that
mark But the issue is as well that we
talk about trauma I was listening to an
interview with Dr Steve Peters who wrote
the chin Paradox and the former guest on
trigonometry and he actually says that
there are some traumas that can never be
overcome
because the hard wiring of the brain
particularly if it happens I think it's
below the age of nine or ten it's just
hardwired there and there's not a lot
you can do about it you can learn to
cope with it you can learn to find ways
to deal with it but you're never in a
sense going to be able to overcome it do
you agree with that
I'd say there's a lot you can do and
this is you know for example if I'm
educating people about trauma one of the
things I'll say is hey here's how you
might spot it and I've heard soldiers
for example in Ukraine go wow I didn't
realize that's why I'm drinking or
that's why I'm finding it hard to be
with my wife well that's why I'm getting
irritated with my kids so just education
is brilliant first of all just learning
about it
um there are definitely things you can
do to make it better I mean I am a case
study of that you know I grew up in a
pretty rough household and I have a good
marriage I have a good job I'm
relatively healthy physically
um there are effective treatments out
there there are things that work you
know so for example one of the things
that is I sign post people I say hey you
might want to check out this therapy and
they say I don't like talking about my
feelings like no problem you might want
to check out this one well you don't
have to talk so there are a bunch of
stuff out there that um works and one of
the main messages I have when I meet
people with trauma is like there's there
is hope you know I've definitely seen
that you know my mental works with
abused children for example some of the
worst cases you can imagine I've worked
in multiple War zones and there is hope
and um there's a lot we can do
um there's cultural stuff around that
like some whole cultures are traumatized
like I've worked on Israel in Russia and
Ukraine and there are whole cultures
where trauma has become almost normal
and that's pretty interesting to me too
so what are the symptoms of someone
who's traumatized how do they how does
it manifest physically how does it
manifest emotionally okay so two main
sets of symptoms we've got uh
hyperarousal symptoms and numbing
symptoms so you can think of it as too
much or too little the nervous system
being shut down or wired or some
combination thereof
hyperal symptoms uh sleeplessness so for
example one of the reasons I used to
drink is because I couldn't sleep now I
can sleep fine without any kind of
sedative right but I was hyperous that's
anxiety sleeplessness I'd wake up
absolutely buzzing uh you'll see this in
Israel people just wired and I wanted a
holiday there my wife's like because
she's Ukrainian so she can go on holiday
that fairly easily without a Visa and
she went it's a beautiful place Tel Aviv
and the food's nice and your friends are
lovely they've got lots of good friends
there but she said it's not very
relaxing
you know yeah uh so and I can feel that
I can walk in a room and go okay this
trauma here these people are have got
that nervous system state where they're
in that fight or flight and that can
manifest in loads of ways like how
people think you know their politics
they want they're scared so they want a
politician to be more authoritarian
right
um or they're paranoid like this you
know the scarcity there's a sense of not
enough and you've got to fight for yours
um there's a certain way of looking at
the world and it also may affect like
the digestion it may affect the um
immune system it may affect sexual
systems so like there's loads of ways
that being wired could manifest and then
the other side of things is the shutdown
so that you know the the Russian smile
you know that's the uh emotional numbing
where sometimes numb people hurt people
because they don't have that normal
emotional response to another suffering
that's where it's dangerous
um they might just feel cut off from
life you know I remember just coming
back from some places and just being
very blank you know slight thousand
yards there all the sort of
lack of emotion rather than hyper
emotion and then people self-medicate in
different ways right so let's say
someone is hyper they might use alcohol
or you know opiates to come down if
someone's not feeling they might be I
don't know have a crazy sex life or do
bungee jumping or something just to feel
alive there's ways people try and
medicate those issues I say a key thing
that comes out of it is the damage it
does to relationship
it is hard to be in a trusting intimate
relationship with trauma
um that's why so many like British
servicemen for example get divorced it's
where you assembly firemen and policeman
have problems nurses have problems in
their marriages
um or with their kids so uh yeah how it
affects intimacy the flight system is
going to antagonistic to our kind of
connect sort of more mammalian
connection system so um in this
neurological reasons for this that
others are better educated Than Me In
it's really really interesting and the
way that you've broken it down and the
way you've displayed because I used to
work in a school everybody drink but one
of the signs that we knew if a child had
suffered sexual abuse is because they
were hypersexual at an age before they
before puberty for example or if they
were going through puberty they were
hypersexual and before people would look
at a child behaving like that yeah and
shame them for it but now because we
have better knowledge we look at our
children and go okay there's something
going on here this needs investigating
yeah I saw that in the slums of Brazil
when I worked there and it was pretty
disturbing to see but it's a warning
sign or even little things like case
where a lot of kids in England and if
you tap a kid on the shoulder a normal
kid will um go oh yeah they won't do
nothing they won't just sit there like
learn helplessness and they won't go you
know they won't get paranoid or attack
you or anything like that they'll just
go oh someone's tapped me on the
shoulder and you see that right through
to adults and how they respond to things
you know do they respond with apathy and
not doing anything or like a hyper
vigilance
so you know you guys talked a lot love
your podcast by the way I'm a fan and
you guys have talked a lot about
activists and people who are kind of you
know they're hyper Vigilant a lot of the
time they're looking for something
that's hurt them they're looking in a
paranoid kind of way it's guy you must
be a racist you must be a sexist that's
not the only thing that's going on but
one of the things that's going on is
that people have been hurt they've been
abused and they
um
have come to see the world as a
threatening place and they're looking
for threat everywhere
I think also
um and you tell me what you think about
this but my impression is as well is
there is a certain validation but if you
are not in a healthy Place yourself yeah
and you don't want to deal with that and
you don't want to admit that and you
don't want to consciously be aware of
that
it's very comforting to say well the
world is messed up right I'm fine I'm
fine the world's messed up and that's
why I'm gonna go out there and you know
do these things to fix the world then
I'll feel fine whereas I don't think
that's really how it works no I mean if
I feel unsafe if I feel unwell in my
body the place that goes to myself now
there may be a societal context to that
I mean gamble is absolutely right that
there's you know certain conditions I
think poverty is one of the biggest ones
yeah people just don't talk about it's a
big problem people don't talk about
poverty in the UK I think but the the
idea that you can't fix yourself through
trying to fix the world you're in the
wrong location but in a way it's
appealing because
turning in on yourself really looking at
your issues addressing things that's
difficult that takes real courage so
it's much easier to go out there in the
world and if there's a societal system
that says that makes you a good person
and I think one of the big problems in
our society is that we don't have a way
to be good
like if you were in feudal Japan or
ancient Greece or even more than China
there's a clear way to establish virtue
and we need that and it's almost a very
old-fashioned idea it's talked about
ethics and virtue and morality but we
need that as people we need a way to be
good and in the absence of that people
will adopt whatever they're offered
which may be a good consumer or a good
social justice person it's like all you
have to do to be good is this is say
this thing on social media right so it
offers people a cheap and easy way to be
good and potentially they feel that
there's some going to be some sort of
healing in there
um which they could be there could be
there is a point in post-traumatic
growth where people help others and
that's part of their own their own
healing
um but I've yeah I've definitely seen a
lot of trauma in the kind of activism
world and I think it would be a lot
kinder
uh if that trauma was healed hey KK Do
You Believe In Spring cleaning yes but
only when my wife does it in Russian men
who cleaner executed for not being real
men which is correct well for those men
who aren't living in the 21st century
manscape has an incredible offer for you
manscaped are the global leaders immense
below the waist grooming and have
forever changed the grooming game with
their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20
percent of and free shipping with the
code trigger 20 at manscape.com it's
time to throw out all your old hygiene
habits and upgrade your life
but there's also the glamorization of
trauma and the glamorization of
victimhood so we come from the comedy
industry yeah uh and you just see people
go you know they talk about their
depression and it becomes a badge an
identity of I'm depressed and you think
to yourself well this may be true and as
somebody who has seen people in their
family suffer from a real severe
crippling depression
you go well that might be true but how
is it helping you what you were doing
and if you make an idea if you identify
as depressed
are you going to want to get better
right because that's now who you are
right so if someone's I've had people
introduce themselves at workshops
by talking about their trauma and I'm
like well unless that's the point of
what we're doing that's strange to me
um it's kind of like trauma's kind of
like having a cup you know half of us
have got one but don't introduce
yourself at parties by getting it out
you know for me it's a little it's a bit
much and if people are stuck it there's
a there's a time when you need to say I
was abused all my people were abused
right your Ukrainian or Jewish or
whatever it is all right there's a time
when that's helpful
rather than saying it was nothing I
remember the first time I went to a
therapist 20 odd years ago or whatever
and I was saying yeah I had an alcoholic
dad and my cousin killed herself but
it's nothing it's not a big deal right
and he was like uh
you know maybe so um there is a time
when it's helpful to adopt a trauma
identity sort of it as a passing thing
but I think getting stuck there and if
there's a culture in society that gives
you kudos for being a victim actually
that doesn't help healing what helps
healing is empowerment you get over
trauma by being empowered right this is
where soldiers don't get traumatized
when they're fighting so I'll just get
traumatized when they're being shelled
right like in World War One or on the
Eastern front now in Ukraine why because
they're not empowered when they're
fighting they have a sense of power they
have a sense of agency so you know
victim is the opposite of agency it's
the opposite of healing the other thing
that's critical relevant to you guys is
to me the opposite of traumas actually
play
so having a sense of humor like my my
mentors is Wiley old Jewish Golan is
always making all these jokes and some
of them are just like they're pretty on
the edge and the jokes he makes with his
patients they're coming from a good
place and they're very healing it's very
much part of Jewish culture and my my
experience of Jewish mentors it is yeah
well it's interesting I don't think
that's true of all Jews actually because
I mean nothing's true of all Jews but
according to the labor party
um but uh I I remember I did a a show at
the Jewish Center in London yeah and
they really didn't like my show actually
okay um which is fine people are allowed
not to like my comedy but uh well they
shouldn't be but they are
um but what happened was afterwards
there was like a q a and somebody said
like why why is you why is your like why
is your humor so dark wow and I was like
well where I'm from in the former Soviet
Union like and I told this joke about
how after a pogrom after Jews have been
massacred in a town somewhere in Russia
uh the Jews sort of come back and they
find the rabbi uh who's been crucified
on the wall of the synagogue and they
walk up to him and they go rubber rubber
does it hurt and he goes well only when
I laugh and and I said that and they had
the same reactions France is like am I
allowed to laugh at that but I've always
thought that is the way the Jewish
people in those parts of the world where
they experienced awful trauma learn to
process it and a lot of the Jewish jokes
that I grew up with in in Russia in
Uzbekistan and Ukraine they were based
very much on that sort of like we've had
a horrible history and we're still
laughing yeah I mean it might be more of
a British thing and the British kind of
Jewish Community I mean the British
ruined Jews I worked a lot of
psychologists in Israel a lot of them
have got pretty wicked senses of humor
that's my experience people can laugh at
things so it's um yeah yeah I I think
it's one of the I think it's something
that actually Britain adds quite well
into the psychology world because
um Americans aren't very funny okay and
they run psychology there are stand-ups
of course who are amazing but as a
culture humor is not valued in the same
way as it is in my family Irish so I'll
say anglo-irish culture banter and
humans just everywhere Australia South
Africa the whole kind of British kind of
area plus Ireland and I think that's
remark human can be remarkably healing
it allows us to take space from
something it's also empowering because
if you can laugh at something it hasn't
got you anymore right like working in
Ukraine last year like with a lot of
jokes and as long as people understand
your life you're not laughing at them
it's not it's not I talk about towards
connection humor rather than away
connection human you can feel if
someone's making a joke because they're
just uncomfortable and they don't want
to connect and they want to go connect
themselves for others
um but I think it's remarkably underused
by psychologists as a healing strategy
and as I said what was lucky my mentor
happened to be um have a sick sick
[__] sense of humor
the other thing before we move on to
your experience of working in war zones
and and all that light stuff
talking about I mean one of the things
as you know we talk about a lot is the
impact of social media in the world and
the culture War and the anger that seems
to exist and everyone's constantly
bickering and fighting and we've you
know we've had our fair share of it
ourselves and and been involved doing it
too like how how do you see the impact
of social media and the internet on the
work that you do
I'll broaden that questionnaire if you
don't mind yeah we're in a disembodied
world so what I mean by that is we're we
are regulated by self-regulation
co-regulation we could say
eco-regulation like we're in beautiful
countryside here you know as soon as I
got out of the car so I was like oh
that's nice you relax you know as soon
as I had dinner with you like lunch with
you guys we chat we eat together move
together laugh together you co-regulate
self-regulation I meditated this morning
right it's actually the least important
I'd say those three and Theo regulation
a term one of my Greek colleagues made
up uh meaning like regulated by meaning
and Western Civilization has lost a lot
of its sense of meaning and the sacred
yes we've lost connection to Nature
particularly in the big cities I find
I'm in London on the weekend there's
super stressful compared to where I live
in the countryside we've lost a lot of
co-regulation I mean particularly you
know during the Chinese plague that was
um
I'm going to call it that uh during the
Chinese plague it was really uh
co-regulation was almost under attack
and you could be more or less
conspiratorial about that but no faith
this this is what says I'm okay you're
okay right we don't like having babies
hate it if you cover your face right
right or you play a game by covering
your face and then smiling because they
go get scared and they go it's fine yeah
um so this was covered we weren't
allowed to touch we weren't allowed to
be around each other like that's what
keeps human beings sane like that is
literally the the basis of our sanity it
is amazing how under made that point was
during the pandemic because it was like
well you've got to wear the mask because
it's for everyone's benefit I mean very
questionable by the way but we won't go
there
um but also like that side of it was
never discussed almost almost no one
went actually this is really bad for
human beings co-regulation is the
essence of physical health like mental
health but even just physical health
like old people die without Touch
without love without connection babies
die without this thing either die or if
you feed them they're like the Romanian
orphans they grow up you know unwell
psychologically you know even if you
feed them physically remember the
Romanian author yes I do yeah so they
were physically looked after but they
didn't have any touch actually there's
one beautiful
tragic story from Romanian orphans there
was one kid by the light switch and
there was hundreds of kids in this room
and every day the janity would come in
and turn the lights on and off on the
morning off the evening and as he was
doing that he would just ruffle the hair
of this kid right and that was the only
kid that developed in that room full of
hundreds of kids right just from one
touch a day that's how important it can
be it's beautiful and sad at the same
time and yeah we we were already already
in a culture which is
um lacking not that's not even a strong
enough word which is in poverty of human
touch and connection and we're a
community we're in poverty when it comes
to community in this culture compared to
our actual ancestors who grew up in and
I won't idealize them but they have one
thing most tribal communities did have
is co-regulation and um and then with
that ritual you know with that like one
of my students was saying the other day
why do I feel like an imposter and I'm
like because the whole village hasn't
initiated you into this career you know
you haven't had the seal of approval of
your elders you haven't you know you're
not part of a community that has ritual
and meaning and a shared religion and
all the rest of it
um so that's and not having that sense
it's crazy being online sends us crazy
it's like being sat still since it's
crazy like when we sit we gradually lose
our feeling sense you do that all day
long staring at a computer
and social media is a conspiracy I mean
it is it is it's literally designed to
keep us anxious so we spend more on the
advertising it's not you know someone's
evil they just want to make more money
right so it is a conspiracy in that it's
designed to put us into fight or flight
so it's designed to put us into a trauma
State essentially yeah yeah because if
we're in that agitated we keep scrolling
we keep looking we feel like
you know did you ever have the
experience where you like have really
nice weekend with your wife or your
friends and you're in nature and you're
lots of touch and everything's great you
don't feel like checking your phone no
because you're not anxious it's also
been it's someone told me I think it's a
work of BF Skinner that social media has
been designed with the same principles
as the gambling industry yeah operant
conditioning so it's just reward and
Punishment raise it's there to give you
little little vocabin hits right yeah
and it's and once you start chasing that
dopamine it's drug-like so you're you
get that hit and then you want ever
increasing amounts of dopamine and what
used to get you high now no longer does
so you're wanting the bigger and bigger
Rush well I'm in long-term recovery I'm
17 years sober right and you know it's
very much like drug addiction as someone
who's been an alcohol and drug addiction
and needing that hair I remember what
it's like to wake up and look at
Facebook straight away you know I have
to put some boundaries around myself
around that you know it's actually quite
nice I don't get Sigma
I haven't checked my phone it's kind of
a relief and I'm not against technology
I you know have a YouTube channel
podcast I think it's amazing that you
guys can reach who you reach you know
without being a big Studio subject to
corporate interests and things so it's
fantastic technology and use with care
use with care and that goes for computer
games porn
just sitting emailing all day but
particularly something like porn or
computer games or social media that's
been designed with that conditioning in
mind so we're disembodied and social
media is a part of that people lose
their empathy when they're disembodied
and basically become temporarily
Psychopathic you know what that is such
a good way of putting it because
I actually use my social media a lot
less the bigger it gets yeah well you
think you think it'd be the opposite I'd
be like Oh I'm on this number now oh
let's keep feeding the machine and
increasingly I'm just like well I don't
like this the way we're having these
discussions and uh it seems to me that
you know we recently
it's like there's a sense that
it it doesn't matter how angry how rude
how destructive your approach is it can
never be angry destructive or rude
enough for a lot of people
and this temporary psychopathy I mean
that's a very good way of describing it
I mean that is the symptom of our
culture generally some cultures lies say
Russian culture even more you know it's
more endemic in some places and you know
it's technologically enhanced here it's
trauma somewhere else and essentially
when you're notching into your body when
you're not got that natural empathic
resonance like if I would imagine a
kitten right fluffy kitten if I were to
take that kid and strangle it to death
any normal person would have a physical
response they go gross right so but if
we're not in our bodies if we're cut off
from ourselves whether it's through big
trauma or being on the internet all day
or whatever it is that natural resonance
isn't there and that is very dangerous
and you see behavior on the internet you
go
would you talk to someone in a pub like
this like one of my rules is don't
accept behavior that would get you a
punch in the head in the pub right like
like people don't do that normally and
actually in life most people are right
most people are pretty Centrist they're
pretty reasonable you know you go on the
internet for five minutes it looks like
there's this huge massive culture war
and I think that wall that has
come into real life to some degree I got
um I got banned from a cafe recently
because they overheard me speaking and
didn't like something I was saying and
would that abandon me from the cafe I'm
like no it's not Facebook mate do you
know what I mean you're not unfriending
me here like we can have a conversation
what was the problem I don't think I was
saying anything too outrageous but I
didn't like my politics or whatever and
um I just remember thinking God this is
creeping a bit into real life well
that's why we are concerned about it on
the one hand on the other hand like we
had a guest on our show Sam Harris and
Sam said some things that I really
fundamentally disagree with but that's
the point of the show you could say
something fundamentally disagree with
and
people went after him in a way that made
us extremely uncomfortable strange isn't
it and I was like okay he said something
that I fundament I think is wrong I also
thought it was dangerous that way of
thinking I didn't like it I didn't agree
with him but people will go after him
like he's the devil yet when someone on
their side attacks someone else with far
more viciousness and unpleasantness and
whatever they are more than happy to see
that happen yeah and if we're not well
regulated and that comes from the
self-regulation the co-regulation Eco
regulation if we're not well regulated
it becomes intolerable and everything's
a life threat trauma sees everything is
a life threat you know everything's life
and death and actually things on our
life left we can disagree on things you
know so who's more attractive South
American mums or east European models
you know we could have that we could
have that debate but um you know we can
disagree we can make silly jokes and
humor can come back in if we're well
regulated I you forgiveness can come
back in in being like hey I didn't like
what you said but you know we can still
get on and I think we look at people
being badly badly regulated and we go
is that that's their fault do more yoga
go do yoga and it's like but the society
is making everyone crazy yeah you know
and we've lost our meaning in society
and we've lost our cultural coherence
and we've lost our connection to Nature
it's a little [__] yoga class twice a
week isn't really going to cut it you
know and go do the ogre I love yoga yoga
it's great we do martial arts we've been
talking about I think martial arts are
fantastic but honestly you need
Community you need friends you need good
relationships you need nature you need
all these things that we evolved to have
and to keep us sane and um in the
absence of that people get pretty
prickly to say the least and we've been
fed a lie in that you know it's social
media it's a way to build communities
it's a way to find friends it's a way to
make friends and look some people do
make friends online I'm not I'm not I'm
not denigrating that but the reality is
it's a very very poor and pale imitation
of what you can find IRL as the kids say
yeah I mean porn is the sex right and
you know Facebook friends aren't real
friends and these you know I think you
can create networks to make them
friendlier like we have a Facebook group
that's pretty for our company it's
pretty friendly and people are pretty
cool there because we just don't
tolerate anything else and then you know
we tolerate different views but not
personally insulting people yeah it's
Behavior you prevent exactly we say you
can say anything you want here but you
can't say in any way you can't
personally insult people
um certain platforms may be friendlier
but personally I I look at it like going
to a dangerous country you know I go to
Instagram half an hour a week do my q a
you know interact a little bit with some
positive people and I turn that off my
phone sometimes I'll even delete the app
really yeah I'll delete the app because
you have to I'd have to be better on
Wi-Fi again to upload it again I just I
treat it like a job it's like going to
Afghanistan and coming out again kind of
thing you know and as I said it can be
positive but um it's not what we're
wired for it's not what makes us healthy
and um without without embodied practice
there's there's real problems so we're
talking about Instagram being like
Afghanistan and you have worked in war
zones
I mean the obvious question is what is
that like because because for most
people listening and watching this they
have no idea thankfully it's a lot of
fun
um if you didn't expect that yeah
um if you have deep-seated trauma
um I mean the first time I worked in a
corporation I went oh this feels like a
war zone so like the nervous system of
the average business in London is like
it wasn't like I was like oh this is
familiar I was familiar from my
household growing up it was familiar
from places I've worked and when I went
to a war zone part of me just relaxed
and went okay now the Danger's real now
I can actually accommodate this I can
actually do things to prevent this
um so I mean I've worked post-conflict
and places that are actually quite nice
like Cyprus I don't want to overstate
this it's not like I'm sort of you know
getting shot out on the front lines or
something or I mean going to live for
example it was anxiety provoking and I
remember you know the first we're doing
it I believe just for people who don't
know is Western Ukraine yeah yeah so
we're doing a trauma training there was
like week two of the war as well so the
war broke out
I wanted to go fight that was my first
response I thought this is a violation
this is not okay and I spoke to a few
friends of mine my friend Alex being one
if you're out there Alex good move and
he was like Mark
um you'll probably get shot if you're a
soldier but you're a pretty good trauma
trainer so I said okay we'll go do that
so I went to do a training out there to
the local psychologists were like great
we need help we're overwhelmed you know
you can do a lot with just training
people
and then you know the first alarm goes
off on the first day it's and it's
someone trying to kill you you know it's
a rocket so there's a rocket coming in
your direction and it might be a way off
it might be close you don't know and
there's that moment of like [__] this is
someone trying to kill me and I've had
that many times you know I've had that
in Israel I've had that in West Africa
East Africa slums of Brazil was probably
the place that left the most mark on me
um but you know even though I've been to
a lot of places you could see everyone
immediately does that and I just go
right guys take a breath take a moment
let's walk to the bombshell we've got
three minutes because often people get
hurt panicking and it was pretty
uncomfortable like half the training was
done in a cold car park bomb shelter you
know that was pretty uncomfortable but
then it's also I don't want to play the
violin too much because you know just
around fantastic awesome wise beautiful
cool people
doing something meaningful I mean so
many people lack meaning in their lives
you know doing that project I never felt
like I was my made polish Peaks driving
we're delivering medical supplies that
we've picked up in a pretty dodgy way
but we're helping out because the
hospital was cut off from um it was
getting its supplies in Kiev and at that
point in the war Kiev was surrounded
more or less so they couldn't get
supplies so we picked some up and um
yeah we're driving them there and it's
kind of enjoyable it's like okay this is
a bit dangerous and it's um yeah we've
done risk assessments and things so I
mean honestly the chances were getting
killed were probably one percent or
something like less than that you know
again overstate it compared to someone
who's volunteering on the front lines
um but there was meaning and there was
community and I was working with great
people and they're messaging me today on
the anniversary and there's this this
love and there's meaning and there's all
those things
I mean life purpose is huge right and I
I just I just went I was made for this
you know my mum said don't go because
that's what mums have to do right and I
was like mum come on I wasn't what was I
made for if not this kind of thing you
know this is a perfect job for me
especially because I knew about the
language I had a lot of connections
there you know so um as I said we we did
a training and um eventually actually
the local some local
um psychologists a bunch of young
psychologists tell you what to see
people grow up quick it's a big
difference between a 25 year old and
teaching trauma work in Ukraine the 25
year old in East London I'll tell you
yeah one in East London has probably
seen more man yeah yeah maybe not yeah
yeah so the team were basically just a
bunch of young psychology I went because
I can't do this on my own so I turned up
at local University and just went give
me a psychology graduates who have you
got and then I went to a Convent found a
bunch of nuns who could help and they
were just psychologically trained and
eventually they set up a local charity
so they've been doing it themselves and
they've um very proud of them today
actually they've trained I think it's 30
seen thousand people wow including all
the nurses doctors and teachers in leviv
which is one of the biggest cities in
Ukraine is full of refugees
um so it's probably the most trauma
aware city in the world now
um and they hope to expand it to the
whole country and they've already got
people in Odessa and kieving places
um what are you teaching them
basic psychological first aid so when
people have acute trauma so let's say
you're in a car accident you're going to
have you're going to maybe shaky you're
gonna have that response there's things
you can do that mean that's less likely
to become a long-term trauma response
like what can you do love people
empathize with them appropriate touch uh
there are techniques you can use or
won't get too into here but there's
various kind of psychological techniques
um sometimes it's just uh that
co-regulation of another human being
you know I mean what would you do if
your child fell over and hurt themselves
take them up give them a hug right
totally natural instinct right you touch
I mean obviously you've got to be
careful with touch it's not always the
appropriate thing to do
um a bit of love bit of attention
listening to people sometimes and being
around them giving them some advice
signposting them to useful resources so
instead of going to get drunk they go to
a psychologist or whatever yeah so
psychological first aid uh they're
almost just psychological education so
trauma's different from sort of physical
illness and actually knowing about it
really helps like knowing that that's a
hyper arousal symptom Ah that's why I'm
having problems with my partner
um so they do a lot of psycho psycho
education as well and they and they work
with the you know the psychologists who
are actually doing therapy which is a
whole different thing and you know I can
train people's therapists in 10 days I'm
not a therapist myself
um so um yeah it's brilliant what
they're doing and I'm super proud of all
the girls the millennial girls because
then you're we're young women because
the men are fighting I'm really proud of
them and you know
emotional morning this morning to for
all of us yeah Mark did you get a little
insight into why certain people find War
zones addictive
I mean I used to and the Ukraine was the
first one I'd been to for quite a while
because when I got married I met my wife
who's um As an interpreter in the first
part of the Ukraine conflict because the
conflict now is a continuity of a longer
conflict that's where I met her and I
said I won't do this anymore and I'd I'd
given up because I thought when you're
married it's a bit different you know
and
um
there's an attraction you feel very
alive
so the average office worker in the UK
doesn't isn't on their Edge they don't
feel alive and it was a year ago I was
there and I can feel that like it was
yesterday and sometimes in a positive
way
um but it can take a little bit of
getting used to being back home again
um post deployment or after the event is
quite quite difficult for soldiers and
I've worked with a lot of humanitarians
I've mostly worked with like Oxfam save
the children stuff there and that's
pretty difficult coming home because
your mates are talking about the
mortgage and the football and you're
thinking about dead kids hmm yeah so
it's it's pretty rough like they're
coming home can be shocking and then the
aliveness of being there is in different
places
is um is certainly addictive and I think
these days I've sort of got a bit past
that our next training is going to be
done in Poland I said you know let's do
the you can come to Poland and we'll do
the training there but um yeah it's
interesting that thing that you talk
about the aliveness because we we had
Dan Hardy for my UFC title uh Contender
on the show and he was talking about how
before his big fights he'd like get his
Affairs in order he'd like give books
back to people and movies so that he
could you know like he would go in there
a hundred percent and I I think that
that's a
I think so you're right that so many of
us lack that sense of aliveness uh in
our comfortable lives and maybe that's
the trade-off yeah I mean I found it in
martial arts in the western world and
that's a very healthy way my wife and I
are going to The Climbing Wall recently
which again super healthy thing to you
know have some excitement adrenaline
being a controlled kind of um very
wholesome actually very wholesome
climbing wall just really good nice
people
um so these days I don't feel so drawn
to it you know it was very like and
there's only so much I can take I mean
I'm not the toughest person and the
story I'm supervising essentially so
there's about 100 trainers in Ukraine
right and um this management team and
they speak good English the way
supervise
um online basically and I help out and I
give advice and I listen to them and
yeah sometimes we talk about their
boyfriends and sometimes we talk about
torture chambers and rape and you know
[__] like that and there's only so much
I can take with that
and I I know my capacity now like I know
that I can do that a certain number of
hours a week and then I need to you know
go talk to one of my business clients
about their leadership thing that's much
lighter and um I think Knowing Your
Capacity and this is a big thing for
anyone who's in the NGO world or in the
humanitarian world the or nurse or
anything like that you've got to be
self-aware enough to go okay what's my
limit here and you see like teachers
will burn out from working in the city
schools and stuff as well right yeah you
do you I think as a teacher in a city
school the average person has got about
10 years right I think after that you
just get exposed and you see too much
stuff where and particularly when it
involves children I it just makes far
more of an impact obviously when it
happens to an adult that is terrible and
awful it's rough for kids though yeah
but with a kid in when you see that what
happens to them and what they go through
it it really does leave an impact yeah I
got some some curse on if people want to
have nightmares curse on children's
torture they could Google and people
should know what the Russian military
are doing in Ukraine they should know
because some of it won't be on the BBC
because it's too dark and um you know
that got me way more than stuff I'd I'd
heard about adults you know what should
people know
the extent of what's going on I mean I
in terms of I mean this is I actually
thought that this time this is
trigonometry maybe this is the only
actual trigger warning you should have I
mean a real trigger warning is where you
say hey this could someone who's
watching who has gone through certain
things this could actually put them back
in that and like that's been extended to
me and I'm just a bit upset about your
politics or I don't like your glasses or
something right right so but actual
trigger like I mean there are things
that I go how much do we want to talk
about that in a public space not knowing
who's watching I mean the end endemic
sexual violence of the Russian military
absolutely endemic is heartbreaking and
I get [__] so angry when I think
about it and obviously you know the team
there are hearing different stories from
refugees and first-hand accounts this is
not made up and the problem is the media
have lost everyone's trust particularly
after covid
and Trump breaks it then yeah we've been
lied to so much that people think
Ukraine's a lion actually while the
media presentation may be one-sided
there's a reason it's one-sided one
country innovated another one
um you know some of my friends are a bit
more alternative and conspiratorial will
say is this is that really atrocities in
Ukraine yes there is and I just say
people can look them up and Google them
yeah well it's weird I sometimes get
people on Twitter going if this is a
real war why there's no footage and I'm
like I can show you 50 telegram channels
yeah loads of food yeah
um
so endemic sexual violence
yeah I'd rather not go no no I'm not no
no one wants to go into the graphic
detail I'm just saying I think people
should hear the sort of slightly more
generalized version of the things that
people are dealing with yeah I mean so
look at the history of of what was the
Soviet military
so people don't know this but Berlin was
raped on mass not just Berlin women in
Poland you've got nothing to do across
Eastern Europe absolutely across Eastern
Europe yeah yeah and but in Berlin they
think Berlin alone may have been one
million yeah
um just an absolute Nightmare and that
no one's ever prosecuted you can see
Youtube footage of you know guys that
were on TV in the 70s laughing about it
old soldiers from Soviet soldiers so do
you know Soldier knitson he has a whole
short story and he's talking uh he was
very traumatized actually by what by
witnessing a gang rape by Soviet
soldiers yeah I mean horrific stuff and
I knew it would happen so when I spoke
to my team I said you need to get ready
to hear some stories because I I just
went a it does always happen in war to
some extent horrible as that is but
particularly with the historical
precedent and particularly with a
traumatized country that's already got a
lot of numb people
so like if it happens in war anyway but
for example there's very few instances
of Israeli soldiers doing that in Israel
and there's reasons for that
historically and how the militaries are
and the accountability now not to say
they don't do other things that may be
not okay but that's just not that it's
just not that and
um yeah certainly the civilian targeting
it's not just the odd missile that's you
know a friend of mine was in the area of
Kiev that's just being shelled by
artillery and it was absolutely totally
civilian air and it was Sheldon for days
maybe weeks on end
uh my mother-in-law was in a town far
away from the front line and doing a
shopping and um the shopping center
opposite was blown up and you know an
old lady jumped on her and stopped her
getting killed and she ended up having
dust covered in her and you know there's
a picture of a pram with a child's foot
next to the pram and that was just out
that was literally
20 meters from where my mother-in-law
was you know so these are first-hand
accounts we're talking about here you
know and um yeah maybe there was a
military meeting at the back of the
shopping center someone had said or
something like this but um the civilian
targeting is absolutely clear what's
going on it's a it's a terrorizing and
it's a genocide it's not
you were having a war and in war you you
know sometimes you break eggs to make
omelets kind of thing it's not that it's
not that at all so the civilian
targeting uh would be another one and
you know what goes on every every time
they push back the Russians and butcher
was the first time it was gonna be my
team before and after butcher was two
different it was kids and then it was
adults in that team after Butcher and
that's because it was the first time
Russians were push back and then they
discover things and Buju was Tiny
compared to things since
so what's going on behind the lines kids
being abducted and taken to Russia I
don't know but every time that line is
pushed back and you know that seems to
be god-willing the Ukrainian military is
doing a great job
I mean you know Putin and is losing and
the Russian military is is incompetent
despite still being very dangerous
um it's not my expertise to talk about
military matters
um however you know Putin increasingly
to me looks like a week old man
and
as he is pushed back we will see the
extent of some of these atrocities
because most of the land that was taken
a lot of the land that was taken is
still there
and so and so what do you do with a
population like that
where
awful terrible things like the like the
events and the acts that you have spoken
about
what what do you do after the event
after the event to create some kind of
heat
yeah it's a good question I mean what
normally happens is it doesn't heal then
it just repeats so you see yeah the
Middle East Russia is a case study of
that right well actually I was going to
ask you this not to interrupt your train
of thought but you you've alluded
repeatedly that Eastern Europe is a part
of the world that's that people uh carry
a lot of trauma and one of the things I
remember there was a Russian
psychologist whose name I won't remember
now who talks about how Russia is one of
the countries with the highest rates of
domestic violence and physical child
abuse yes uh where it's kind of
considered normal for adults to beat
their children to get them to behave or
whatever and he basically talks about
how that carries through and actually
there was even more interesting there
was somebody
who talked about how if you look at the
sort of things that people search for in
porn by country okay it shows a very
sadistic
uh mentality in certain countries and
Russia's at the top of that surprise me
yeah I mean I know where does that come
from uh lack of empathy where does that
come from trauma and where does that
come from Russia's history I mean you
know Russia's been invaded by everyone
from the Mongols to Napoleon to the
Polish to uh Hitler swedes Lithuania and
then on top of that yeah sweetly
threatened to on top of invaded by the
Swedish how embarrassing and on top of
that they've added their own level of
trauma with the the gulags as you know
you know in your book you detail this
um the level of trauma in the Soviet
system was just a huge and endemic and
this is a wound but it's a huge wound
this is never to excuse any immoral
Behavior you know and if we wouldn't
want to understand it we should
understand that traumatized you know
numb people hurt people yeah because
that natural we're unless we're actual
Psychopaths which is a very small
percentage of the population the
majority obvious like as we were talking
about sexual violence there you know it
feels gross right it's not comfortable
Pleasant subject and that's a normal
human response and that can be cut off
through the numbing of trauma and
particularly when it's endemic and it's
over time and it's multiple periods it
becomes a norm so you see little Russian
kids they're like okay smiley they're
happy they're active they're and in a
few years they're you know the affect is
gone on the face right the the Russian
smile you know that kind of classic
Russian look or in the chest you'll see
the classic tension bands it's called
armoring in body psychology
um you know you can spot a Polish person
in the street in England can't you
because it was a certain look you know
in the body
um so it doesn't mean that everyone who
has trauma becomes abusive or unpleasant
some people go the opposite way they
become very sensitive and compassionate
but there's a good number of people who
that trauma shuts down that natural
empathy on top of that you'll see like
the drug you know Russian men die 10
years younger than Russian women because
of the rates of alcoholism this is the
average life expectancy for a man in
Russia 16 before yeah it's not great so
yeah the self-medication side of things
is there you know they made it recently
not illegal to beat your wife unless you
hospitalize her that's a law in Russia
yeah you can hit your wife unless it
would be hospitalized that's maybe
illegal but you probably won't get
prosecuted you know it works a lot with
the gay community in Russia you'll see
it in the way people other other groups
and make them them and US kind of thing
so it's in the thinking that scarcity of
is not enough and you will see that
worse all across Eastern Europe but
you'll see it worst in Russia and it
kind of gets softer as you there was a
story that that became viral of a woman
who
um the ukrainians were hacking a lot of
communications because a lot of the
Russian soldiers were using mobile
phones and they found messages from this
woman on it I think it was a dead
soldier's phone actually
from his wife saying no I know you're
going to have sex with the local women
but just use a condom yeah that's it in
that footage too yeah my wife showed me
that yeah and you're kind of translated
it
it becomes a coldness to others yeah and
the Russian
um reputation for coldness is not
undeserved that's not you know I've got
it's like the reason I've got lots of
good Russian friends here but I do have
a lot of Russian friends they used to be
colleagues and people can be very loving
and caring once you're on the inside of
that and the same with my Jewish friends
but again that's another trauma thing
it's them and us it's your Insider your
out every time I go to Israel I put on
five kilos because I get fed so much in
that sort of you know you've gotta eat
food or else we're gonna starve to death
it's a drawer pad you'll see it in
Poland too so you used to see it more in
Ireland though it's kind of fading now
because the famine was way back
um so these cultural trauma patterns
exist and they they run through us even
if we ourselves haven't had personal
traumatic experiences and I think it is
important that we talk about trauma at
this level and not let it just become a
middle class Pursuit
I actually emailed a lot of the top
world's top trauma peoples we run
Summits and conferences I know a lot of
these guys and I messaged them before
you created saying any advice and a lot
of them message back saying oh I don't
really know what to say because we don't
really deal with real trauma but I was
like you've made Millions from this it's
big business trauma now now there's
exceptions to that Stephen porgia is
great who does polyvable theory which I
recommend people look up uh David
bacelli has a technique called Tre which
is a shaking drama Release Technique he
was great he's ex-humanitarian so there
are exceptions but there's a true whole
trauma industry now and this kind of
weird middle class far left politics
around it where it just becomes a way to
sort of beat people around the head and
claim status and it also makes people
feel different
big big special yeah exactly exactly you
know nobody wants to be part of the herd
no one wants to be part of the tribe
anymore everybody wants to be you know
separate and have their own unique thing
and in a way these people are feeding
that demand it's capitalism in action
really isn't it there's a market for it
yeah there's a market for it there's a
microphone as soon as we make the victim
sacred then
it it puts it up on a pedestal and the
Jonathan Heights talked about that
better than I can I think what we've
lost is the value of strength
so the ukrainians I know are strong male
and female some strong women I work with
some badass my married one some badass
women you know and the men and they say
things like we love our men they defend
us from attack and I'm like God it's so
nice to hear something nice about men
you know and there's a way in which
um strength in Eastern Europe isn't uh
mocked like you know I mean I've been
staying in East London tonight and I'm
looking around kind of trendy hipster
East London I I just see weak boys dress
like clowns
like come on guys you know like it's not
a virtue to be weak
I think is it someone gives the example
of I I read my dad's eulogy's funeral he
wasn't a perfect man but there was love
there and I wanted to release eulogy and
I was glad I had that martial arts
training
when I wasn't a mess I was able to help
with the parking and greet my uncle and
you know I was glad what I read is
eulogy that I could do I was glad I had
the strength even though I was scared to
go to Ukraine it's not about not being
scared right
um we need that and we need it for life
like life I don't know if people notice
but life is [__] hard like life is
cancer life is your mum having
Alzheimer's right life is like if your
life isn't hard now great let's be
grateful let's be grateful for the we
were saying this at lunch right we live
in this wonderful place like I have a
comparison point
I'm staying in living in this nice
little English town in the west of
England and every day it's like this is
amazing this is so much [__] better
than Afghanistan there's a you know
immigrants aren't mugs they're not
trying to move here because they're
idiots they're trying to move it because
it's nice yeah and this self-hating has
gotta stop you know to actually to
embrace
the western civilization and the
strengths we have even if we're not
perfect and ukrainians want to be
Western you know they're leaning towards
the West that's what Putin doesn't want
but that's their choice and they're not
doing that because they're
CIA manipulators and they're doing that
because it's [__] better yeah that's
why they're doing that you write about
this in your book and it's um you know
for me what's what's missing is is a
practice for that so I'm an embodiment
teacher right it's a traumas part what I
do mostly I'm training coaches you know
who teaches business people and
they didn't have a practice so in Japan
kids do Kendo kids do martial arts all
right some cultures just make the kids
get something meditate or whatever right
we don't have that in the west we used
to have it with sports
we used to have it with sports so you
know there's a saying Waterloo was one
on the playing fields of Eaton because
originally you know we invented all the
good sports here as you know France and
originally Sports were thought of as
character formation and then they became
entertainment or something else they're
originally they're embodied practices
and I see that re-emerging in you know
climbing and other things doesn't have
to be Eastern though it could be and I
feel like that's what we really lack
here is something to a practice that's
called psychologically to build the
value to embody the values that are
there and um you know ukrainians are
fighting to be part of that world and so
many people in this country and other
Western countries are just throwing it
away like it was nothing it's an
observation that I I had some time ago
when I I sort of looked around and I see
that in a world where men are actively
discouraged from being men which is like
what I think is happening uh you see
increasing numbers of young men going to
the gym to get buff right to look at the
impersonation of manhood and and I don't
I don't I mean some people will be
insulted by that description and like
most of the guys over there behind the
scenes they're all good looking boys
yeah uh but it there is it to me it's a
displacement effect where to me what
strength well you were talking about
strength that's not about being six two
and having big guns it's it's about a
mental resilience it's about a
willingness to stand up for things you
believe in it's about a combination of
traits that used to be as you say
considered like necessary and important
and are appreciated by the way by women
in society right and and they can be
built in the gym because you can go to
the gym and face hardship and you can go
to the gym you can go to the gym to look
nice right yeah to look like some
magazine says you should look right but
you can be in the gym and going okay I'm
here for my discipline and this is you
know to do something difficult whether
it's probably Western life now is it's
too easy yeah so it makes us weak right
it's a very simple simple problem we
have it's a nice problem to have
um so cold showers I take cold showers
yeah I you know because it's difficult
yeah right and you make yourself through
it the same way I lift weights but same
with meditating you know I sit quietly
with myself that's not easy I mean I did
a lot of martial arts before I went on a
Meditation Retreat and like five days of
Silence I mean you know from an Irish
background that was [__] a bit much
you know so there's that and then um I
talked to you the same to Francis
earlier that my students we send them to
yoga martial arts conscious dance but we
also send them to improv and that's one
of the things they're most scared of
because that's a social humiliation
potentially you know that takes real
courage I think it's where we respect
the Joe Rogan's and the you know the
different comedians who are in this
space because we know that verbal
strength and the emotional strength to
stand up and tell a joke and it may be
full flat you know that's another kind
of strength so yeah you can work out in
the gym but you can work out in the dojo
you can work out a meditation cushion
there's lots of ways to be you know back
to the beginning of the story right
these are the strengths that I didn't
have
as a 17 year old who'd read every book
in the library
Wikipedia isn't solving all the world's
problems
we don't need more information you can
get your phone out and have all the
information you want but how are we
training ourselves and we need to
because you know if Ukraine isn't coming
to the door now and it might but if you
if a war isn't coming to the door cancer
is or divorces or your kid could get ill
God forbid or do you know what I mean
it's like something's coming life
happens man so it's like if being weak
is actually irresponsible
being being weak makes you a liability
to the tribe what does it mean to be
weak to not be able to handle adversity
and I don't necessarily I think there's
levels of it right so there's a physical
strength and maybe if you're 80 years
old you don't have that when you're 80
you might have a lot of emotional
strength yeah the person that can read
the eulogy the person that can talk to
their friend who's been sexually
assaulted and actually be with her when
you're hearing things you don't want to
hear you know the person that can just
get up in the morning and go to work
because they've got but I put food on
the table that kind of resilience
there's layers to it right so physical
ethics part of that to be relatively
healthy I think is is a helpful thing it
can be a good foundation I think martial
arts are a great training you know if I
was running the school system I you know
would abs like the Japanese I would make
that mandatory kind of Scholastic kind
of thing
but just having this mentality is the
kind of weak point of the West that we
we have some great strengths in the west
and it's again I'll be the first to tell
them but we
tend to be a bit cognitive within the
way we think we we're not going to think
our way out of this one so um yeah for
me I was glad I had that training doing
the Ukraine project tried to pass some
of that on and I always say to the to
the people that I do your practices you
know do your yoga do your meditation to
do what you can because when if you're
self-regulated as well as you can be
when you're with other people you can
pass that on yeah and it's about
confronting adversity that to me is
strength it's it's been prepared to work
on your weaknesses like we've used the
analogy of the gym and you know young
guys going to the gym to me it's it's
seeing a guy who's buff on top and he's
got little chicken legs you know parsnip
body is what I call them yeah yeah so
facing things that are difficult
deliberately and systematically you
can't just people say oh parenting's my
practice that's not a practice because
life's just throwing stuff at you I
can't say to my partner can you be 20
less annoying because I'm trying to find
The Sweet Spot here you know
um so the beautiful thing about a gym or
a dojo or somewhere where there's kind
of that kind of control is we can find
that spot that's difficult but not
traumatizing like a good Aikido Dojo a
good Karate Dojo they won't traumatize
you they will challenge you yeah same
you know weightlifting you put a mount
on the bar that challenges you
um and if we're not challenging
ourselves then yeah we will be gradually
getting weaker and then when life throws
something too much at us we will break
and we'll not only let ourselves down we
will let our loved ones down and that's
unacceptable
yeah and I don't think we talk about
that enough
no no we pretend that strength is a vice
and weakness is a virtue and it's not
why do we do that
I don't know
I think potentially the emasculate their
mask emasculation of Western cultures
there's potentially an agenda there
I think we've confused cognitive knowing
with wisdom and with
uh skills acquisition so it's a problem
in understanding what learning is like
the English verb to learn actually means
a bunch of things
um
I mean a weak populace is easy to
control right if we wanted to get if we
wanted to get our tinfor hats out
right we're we're easily manipulatable
if we're we're nice consumers perhaps if
we're not in touch with our own values I
mean an advert says by X right now if
I'm tuned in to myself and I go do I do
I need X can I live without X do I feel
resonance for that do I want that
so I think it's potentially something to
do with the wider system but it's a bit
above my pay grade so I think I'll say
I'm not sure about that one
Mark and uh on that happy note yes uh we
uh it's been an absolute pleasure
speaking with you actually just uh it's
interesting you mentioned about having a
controlled environment because I always
get really frustrated when I go and play
basketball somewhere and I'm not a good
basketball player but if the level is
not good enough for me I I can't play
that because you're not on your Edge
right yeah and I the level like ideally
everyone has to be better than me like
that's my sweet spot a bit better though
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't want to play with Michael
Jordan I mean I'd love to play with
Michael Jordan but I don't think it'd go
well
um but anyway it's been a pleasure
having you on the show uh and the last
question we always ask is what is the
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should be I want to say
YouTube first of all I'd say look up
same Ukraine the charity in Ukraine
financially not connected with me
independently run if people want to
support that
um thing we're not talking about
um
gratitude
we mentioned it at lunch
I think
it's I got a bit angry today you know
some of the things we're talking about
kind of before I get my blood up you
know and
I'm really grateful to live in the UK
I'm really grateful we have peace
I'm super grateful to you guys I want to
say a personal thank you you know like
watching this show made me feel less
lonely when there was canceled culture
things happening in my life a few years
ago you know I'm personally grateful and
um I think gratitude is the emotion of
enough
and in a consumer culture
where the tech apparatus is set up set
up to make us feel not enough and to
want more and to be anxious
anything that brings out that feeling of
you know what I'm really grateful and um
that is a cure for a lot else so um
thanks for reminding me of that today
guys perfect well thank you for coming
on and if people want to find you online
where's the best way to do that or your
courses or your work yes uh the word
embodiment if you put that into Amazon
Instagram uh Tinder grinder
um embodimentunlimited.com we've got an
app we've got a website loads of free
resources on trauma and other things
there embodimentunlimited.com
Mark Walsh thank you so much for coming
on the show thank you guys for watching
and listening we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or raw show all of them go out at
7pm UK time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it is
always available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
what does he think about people claiming
to have PTSD often someone has disagreed
with them online and how does their
trauma compare with that with people
who've been in war zones
[Music]
thank you